so you're in a museum looking at the
Picasso you've heard the name a million
times you know the influence you know
he's one of the most important artists
of the 20th century you know he invented
cubism you know he loved women lots of
women and you know he wasn't that great
to them you know he had phases the blue
period the Rose period
neoclassicism surrealism but the
painting you're looking at the one in
front of you you've never seen it before
it's called night fishing at Antibes or
auntie you don't really know you don't
speak French the little card next to it
doesn't say much but you want to know
more about it
how the way I see it you can look at any
Picasso in five different ways the first
and often the best way to understand any
painting is simply to look at it
describe to yourself the objects and the
actions that you see the night-fishing
for example what you see is to spear
fishermen hunting for fish from a small
boat but by a mesmerizing light at the
top of the canvas one fisherman leans
strongly into the water with his spear
hesitating before delivering the final
blow to a fish while the other leans
languidly over the edge looking anxious
a fishing line tied to his foot in the
upper left we can see two towers and a
mass of purple shapes while around the
fishermen fly moths or insects lit by
the light curving over the back of one
of them toward the right side of the
frame where two women one with an
ice-cream cone and a bicycle gesture to
the men who don't seem to notice that
much I find my first reactions to this
entire painting to be a bit
contradictory on the one hand there
seems to be a violent foreboding
character to the scene the central focus
is clearly the hand and the spear and
the fish but there also seems to be an
equilibrium here and the balance of
colors and figures an almost magical
view into an all too ordinary activity
of fishing at night by lamplight and
that brings us to the second way to
examine this painting understanding the
actual content of the scene it is of
course a night fishing scene and that
light at the top is either the moon or
an acetylene gas lamp which spear
fishermen used to lure fish to the
surface of the water you can see another
one under the boat in the upper left we
can bet that those two towers in the
mass of purple shapes are the Chateau
Grimaldi
by the way has since become Picasso
Museum and the water is the French
Riviera at Antibes a resort town in the
southeast of France where Picasso was
vacationing in the summer of 1939
according to his secretary Picasso had
come across such fishing scenes walking
the town at night after dinner and
proceeded to lock himself in his studio
to work on this really large canvas his
largest since Guernica which was
completed two years before the form of
night fishing is in keeping with
Picasso's evolving style after Guernica
which incorporates holdover elements
from the Cubist period and the flatness
of the canvas and its emphasis on
geometrical shapes but also pulls from
the painters excursions into both
surrealism and primitivism where bases
become masks indeed and so much of this
painting in the Cubist period and beyond
the key point to remember is that
figures are painted not as they're
perceived but as they're conceived
Picasso adds to each body elements that
signify two other bodies and to the
canvas as a whole for this reason the
critic Douglas Morgan is right to say
that we can't call Picasso's people
distorted or grotesque because they
haven't been distorted from anything
there's no version of reality in which
they're undistorted in night-fishing
that people are not meant to be
sympathize with the normal reaction to
an undistorted figure they're meant to
be seen that naked seeing that
discernment communicates his meanings
more directly and what are those
meanings well there are a couple ways we
can apply what we see in form and
content to find out first it's worth it
to look at the historical context the
painting was completed in August 1939
just a couple weeks before the outbreak
of World War two life in Europe was
extraordinarily tense and it was
exceptionally so for Picasso who is
still reeling from the sad conclusion of
another conflict the Spanish Civil War
and the defeat of the Republican forces
by Francisco Franco and his nationalist
army Picasso opposed Franco in his work
most notably in Guernica which is one of
the most startling anti-war paint
in history and in some ways
night-fishing in Antibes can be seen as
a companion piece to Gernika instead of
depicting all the violence of the former
picasso shows a moment of hesitation the
spear is likely to skewer the fish but
it hasn't yet a moment of choice opens
up and with choice there's hope
the painter draws attention to this by
making the hand gripping the spear the
most realistic depiction in the canvas
and as we move outward from that focal
point things become increasingly warped
and yet even with this hesitation the
scene is suffused with a sense of almost
apocalyptic apprehension the light at
the top resembles a spiraling comet as
much as it does a moon or a lamp
juxtapose next to a frightening blotch
of red the paintings only use of that
color the moths are like portents
buzzing around the heads of the
fishermen the jetty that the women stand
on is unsteady the town in the
background is a mess these feelings
could be oppression imaging of the
coming destruction of Europe certainly
the feeling in the air was hard to miss
but more likely these dark undertones
reflect an ongoing personal struggle
with the loss of Picasso's native Spain
- a vicious dictator but we're still
missing one giant piece of the puzzle
the personal context what was going on
in the artists own life in this respect
it's worth it to ask who these people
could possibly represent first let's
look at the women while they both seek
to get the attention of the fishermen
they do so in different ways but one
closest to them and in the closest
proximity to the light spreads her arms
in a graceful pose the other is more
blase licking her ice cream cone her
obviously really very obviously phallic
head and pronounced breasts makes her
the more sensuous of the two and though
certainly a misogynistic distinction
these two women likely represent
Picasso's wife Olga and the combination
of his mistresses Maria Therese Walter
and Dora Maar who was with Picasso in a
team and finally the spearing fishermen
can be read as Picasso himself or
perhaps the version of himself that he
wants to be headstrong looking forward
at his goals undaunted by distraction
but this man seems to be linked with his
partner perhaps Picasso's other half a
side of himself that is
passive that ties a fishing line to his
toe and weights whereas the first
fisherman is defined by strong
perpendicular lines the seconds body is
a mass of curved lines and contorted
limbs remembering the historical context
and the stark defiance that is Guernica
what we might be seeing here is Picasso
coming to grips not only with passivity
and weakness in his nature but the
artists impotence in the face of the
world's brutality his mother had died at
the start of the year and Spain was lost
maybe this is why the boat floats in a
weird no-man's land between the town and
the women maybe this is why the scene
feels uneasy
despite being beautiful in its rendering
there's more you can read into this
painting and the rest of macaws work but
these five angles always start me down
some fruitful paths and each individual
method of understanding is less
important than the ways all of them
connect and feed into each other the
historical context usually informs the
personal and the form grows out of the
content and your first reaction is often
surprisingly incisive if you take the
time to voice it or write it down
Picasso's legacy looms so large that the
scholarship on him is vast and often
contradictory so my feeling is why not
decide the significance of his work for
yourself